I only use Instagram I use tick tock too
I don't really look at I don't look at
Tick Tock I look at Instagram it's the
only one I look at I posted a thing
since it was pride month I think all
dudes should [__] dudes straight up
I wish I could do it but it's like
you know bungee jumping for me I just
kind of I don't want to you know but if
I did I would do it dude like you know
so I put and I I
um hashtag Pride on it just as a joke
and and it they make it rainbowy which I
didn't know that if they did that maybe
I wouldn't
bro the [__] people
look I'm out of here sell out that he
says
chill bro
I'm actually gonna unfollow LOL
Chris is falling off now with this BS
look at Illuminati got him
the other guy [__] done with this
dude
guy right so woke dude it's the opposite
look sold his soul soul he said
bro really not you as well they acting
like
I'm on these front lines
dude
everyone's a [__] I don't give a [__]
but also
I'm the you got the wrong guy unfollow
why won't this [__] charge my phone
won't charge great good I don't
understand the the the people on the
internet they just the Internet isn't
real dude do you know that
do you know the Internet isn't [__]
real it's absolutely Bonkers it's crazy
dude
like I kind of want to be on everybody's
side but the interview that's why I say
don't push me the internet makes you
have to pick a side and if you don't
then they'll do it for you I didn't even
know pride has to do with all of the the
lgbtqs all of them not just gay it used
to be just gay and now it's like yeah
get them all involved all right fine
dude
it's crazy how much
they're they're promoting this [__]
these companies okay now I don't really
give a [__] because who cares but but
dude I turned on one of the apps
like uh
I don't remember which one it was you
know I got HBO I got I got I got all
right Max I got Paramount I got Netflix
I got all the different ones I turned on
one of them Disney I don't know which
one it is dude and
I get it first of all I kind of think
everyone is kind of on the spectrum of
gayness right like you either don't I
think there's a spectrum right you
either blast dudes you think about
blasting dudes
or you just simply don't blast dudes
right now I think a lot of those people
who blast dudes are living their best
lives a lot of those people who think
who think about blasting dudes kind of
think that they should be blasting dudes
but they're not doing it because society
says and I think that a lot of the
people who don't blast dudes are over
correcting because they want to blast
dudes but then there is that Minority
we're really we just don't want to blast
dudes and that's where I fit in okay I
think unless my subconscious is really
really good
or bad I should say maybe it's
overcompensating right
but
I'll tell you right now to your straight
to your face I'm blasted zero dudes just
period zero kissed one guy and it was a
joke and it was in high school we were
both in high school and then we were
doing it we were just like ah come on
let's kiss on the lips hahaha and I did
it and it was in front of some chicks
and we were all having a you know as a
laugh but it felt weird you know and I
think it actually felt weird because it
felt weird and I've never done it before
not because
it actually I was like stirring up some
[__] in my
because otherwise I'd be blasting dude
Central at this point you know me right
but um
anyway uh
if you turn on apps
first of all every three months is pride
month I don't give a [__] what everyone
says I I see it all every time this
probably month I'm like didn't this [__]
just no okay
sometimes I wish I was gay so I could be
like [__] this month man just let me be
gay and chill but this this is crazy
dude I turn on this streamer and it had
it was like celebrate your
you know
the gayness of everyone and then also
trans and then
and it had the people on the thing they
looked like it was they were shooting a
sketch
you know it was like
you couldn't tell if it was a guy or a
girl in a hat
and he was and then another person it
was like I don't know what that person
is and then they had two guys that
looked like gay guys and I was like cool
fine but then it's like I just want to
watch the floor is lava you know
and it's fine
but it would here's why it bothers me
because the corporations actually don't
give a [__] that's why it bothers me
because they don't care and so gays are
like I'm coming up look at this month we
have look HBO Max is involved really
they're just involved because of the
money aspect
but then
I don't know man I don't I don't know I
don't know I don't know about the issues
I don't care about the issues I I think
everybody should be able to live their
[__] lives as long as they're not
hurting each other
and then I understand why somebody who
wants to watch the wire do you know what
I mean and then they turn on some [__]
and you gotta see
you know
like this whole thing about trans women
or whatever in the kindergarten talking
about sexuality with the kids it's like
not so dude it's nutso and honestly
I'm trans so [__] it I'm so not that
though like I'm so not about anytime
that's my problem anytime there's a
somebody wants me to be a part of a
group I'm like nah nah nah no no no no
like when I was in college and they were
like you know we got frats I was like
bro dude you guys there is no [__]
way I'm joining period you know when
people are you know that whole thing
Join or Die all right dude
make the gun talk to me because I'm done
dude I'm not
Join or Die you're gonna be like that
okay
I don't want to [__] join dude that's
why I hate all this pressure to become
you know
vocal about [__] issues when I don't
even know about the [__] issues and I
walk around and I see it in the world
and nobody knows about the issues
they're just like ah I'm just trying to
work
hey can I have a job this is how I feel
if you listen to this podcast you know
it's how I feel crazy crazy crazy
crazy congratulations
[Music]